oh good morning Hank it's Tuesday as you
might notice I'm here in my new office
and I'm walking on my treadmill desk why
did I get a treadmill desk well two
reasons Hank first I am a nerd and I
heard that you could level up in your
nerdiness by getting a treadmill desk so
I was like all right talk about the
second reason we need to go back in time
to Memorial Day weekend when you and I
went to the beach together now Hank you
may remember that we ran into the ocean
both wearing our shirts to protect the
public and then we had an old-fashioned
noodle war you know like people in their
30s do and in that noodle war it was
widely reported that you won but in fact
you did not win because as you can see
right here you abandon your noodle which
is losing anybody who abandons their
noodle has lost the noodle war that's
the rules
so just to be perfectly clear I won the
noodle war however after I won the
noodle war you picked me up and slammed
me into the water and at some point when
you were lifting this nearly 200 pound
mass and then slamming it into the water
I thought to myself Hank has gotten kind
of fit lately and Hank it turns out that
over the last several months you quietly
been doing this exercise regimen that
has resulted in you becoming kind of
buff in fact several people commented
about it on your last video now I didn't
get this treadmill desk just because you
got fit and I'm jealous but I'm not
gonna deny it Hank I was partly inspired
by my Memorial Day Duncan also third
reason hey cuz you know I'm obsessed
with all the ways that in trying to save
ourselves we kill ourselves like all the
ways we act irrationally about health
for instance I'm a big fan of hand
sanitizer but sometimes I use hand
sanitizer while I'm driving and that's
not rational because I'm creating more
risk for myself by using the hand
sanitizer than I would if I just drove
anyway it turns out the people who sit
more than 11 hours a day are twice as
likely to die from all causes over the
next 15 years than people who sit for
less than four hours a day well Hank I
don't need to tell you why this is a
concern to me I live on the internet the
world capital of sitting initially I
thought this might not be a problem
because I usually don't sit
eirick line but it turns out reclining
counts is sitting sitting too much
increase your risk of like heart attack
diabetes certain kinds of cancer so I'm
not gonna do it anymore Hank I'm gonna
be a standard I'm gonna be a stander and
a walker my entire new novel is gonna be
written while walking or this will just
end up like all the other fitness crap
in my basement hank dftba
congratulations on your newfound you
know I'll see you on Friday
all right Hank I'm happy so I'm going to
try this don't try this at home
yes